what's up guys i'm ryan right I am NOT
right right this is Jerry and we're
featuring a special comedian today
people stand up comic in Gutowski well
everybody's right now is going who the
[ __ ] is he yeah understandable i say
that too sometimes I I met Ian he was
the name of your necks of your special
who the [ __ ] is who the [ __ ] is he in
Utah cienega ticketing gutowski I've
never heard your last gate last name
petoskey guitar you shoulda told me I
know it's not you love to be asking it's
a very very easy name before like forget
man what's your middle name I got to
Michael Albert okay you got to encase
dude in Kate's parents were like let's
let you decide I'll bring like an actual
name in and of itself like if you want
to be a novelist you could just do that
yeah Michael Albert no it's like it's
being Catholic you always take your
father's name and then your
grandfather's name that's just like my
yes Derek Michael Laverne guitar ski
geez okay if it's a crazy did I grope
you I'm just making like a chain a name
yeah yeah it's just a massive chain of
words we have to remember everybody who
ever came before us yeah so today I'm
calling this podcast the power of comedy
I have a very special place in my heart
for comedy like I think that's what
separates like the reaction show we have
from a lot of other channels is it
there's a very special comedy in my
heart for places yeah ooh that's deep
that's deep it's in like I took a towel
is a special place in your heart ago oh
yeah there's a special place in my heart
for comedy because in a lot of ways
comedy save me growing up I grew up like
my biggest as far as like comedians go
my first big influence was probably
Conan O'Brien but grow it up like I grew
up on the show friends and one character
I really connected to was Chandler and
Chandler was known to be the defense
mechanism guy who masked everything with
humor I remember learning that and I was
like [ __ ] I should do that I'm in a lot
of pain let me just mask all my pain
with humor little friend should you
imagine yeah Frank show me
so but then along the path you know like
Jerry and I like have we started doing
improv classes together for years and
did a lot of improv shows where we try
doing stand-up and then it enhance our
observation skills and it does give you
a different perspective because everyone
knows comedy stuff like it's hard like I
respect a comedy movie that does it so
well where this is like this movie got
released to the world and the world
laughed like that's hard you know
because normally comedy is very specific
on who you're talking to you or what
your audience is you know so I wish like
the business so to speak would take how
many more seriously because I was like
it's not that easy that like of you it's
not your written a sketch yeah sched
writings hard it's hard to make people
laugh like most of the time it's like
it's one thing to be funny in
conversation it's another thing when
you're like we gotta write some [ __ ] you
know yo you actually have to think about
it yeah hours then the people you've
room full of people if you don't [ __ ]
know yeah we are you doing standing out
there you are you're looking at it just
like oh these are just human beings that
I've never seen different I gotta give
them to like me again breaking the ice
getting today it just goes straight to I
think you're funny yeah exactly is super
and especially when you're presenting
comedy I feel like people I feel like
people go in with this guard like all
right let's see if this monkey will make
me laugh kind of thing you know like I
feel like a lot of people aren't just
all right I'm ready to laugh let me just
be receptive and I'll see when I would a
stand-up show I just want to let like I
want you to make me laugh like I'm not
gonna be like yeah you better like yeah
but there is something and it's an
American thing when you perform another
country's of performing few other
countries and is viewed very much as an
art form we're out here in the States
because of the competitive nature of
America that's the whole will you better
make me laugh that is a so it's tends to
be alive I'm from Canada so I see it but
it's this saturday i'm worth my to drink
a minute yeah yeah that's it so that's
always like my thought process of your
right works just you get those those
crowds sometimes where their arms are
crossed and like oh I've got
earn yeah earn your trust in your lover
yeah yeah you just being open to this
yeah those are tough but they're also
like I like those crowds if i'm doing
like us headline set like 45 minutes cuz
it in like this is my challenge tonight
is to turn this crowd and when you can
do it there's nothing more satisfying
when you go up in there like that and
you've got a five minute spot you don't
have a snowball's chance in hell i'll
turn in that cry yeah you know you just
pick on yourself and pick on them and be
like peace out of done just likely would
ya with a little bit of you know so much
shame on the table but like that is a
that is a thing that I experienced
especially like a light you experienced
that suz you go over the hill man in so
in the Hollywood Hills like you do rooms
out there you pick that up more than
anything Oh totally I I could I actually
see what you're talking about thinking
about like looking back on those moments
what ever been there yeah because you
performed in other countries is it are
the audience is different like cuz I've
heard like it like in certain places
like in Scotland stuff like people will
be more interactive with you like like
their places where you really gotta earn
it because they won't like the fourth
wall isn't a thing yeah and I haven't
performed in Scotland but that is very
like I have one of my good friends
that's out here he started there and
it's like yeah it's a bad and he goes
and they want you to bring it like
that's what they want okay they want you
to beat you over their head so yeah but
then you have other countries like like
your Canada and you know they view it
like they are going to a play or they're
going to see you know they're going to
see a show like that something's us
which is how come you should 0 that's
cool commies most objective art form
which I pit makes it I think the hardest
art form but it seems to be the most
[ __ ] on it so you know it's like you
just clowns and stuff I'm like no these
are your sad wrists these are the people
that are pushing issues as are the
people like like Lenny Bruce and in
Prior yeah what they've done socially
for this country that is pretty pretty
huge you know well that's it like the
comedy and writing both have that thing
where like people approach it kind of
like I could do that like it's not at
least right here like a big like it's
cool to hear that people in Canada like
they treat it like like feel like
they're you know we're engaging in a
show well cuz here it's just like
everybody assumes they could do it and
just didn't have the
so I'm gonna pay you to make me laugh
yeah yeah yeah I'm doing this to the
time right now but I got the extra 15
yeah it's like if everybody sat down if
everybody in America set down tried to
write a stand-up routine I think people
with respected more yeah yeah you're
right yeah I feel like when people walk
out of comedy shows like they watch a
lineup they always just walk out and the
most reflection they have is this person
was funny that person wasn't funny that
person was funny this person was funny
we just remember the people who were
funny and anybody yes especially bad but
like comedy to me like I look at some of
the greatest comics um like currently
Louis CK to me is one of the best comics
and his his stand-up special called
hilarious honestly helped my perception
of a lot of things you know like I i was
having thoughts at the time of we live
in a much better day and age you know
like everything like people would travel
years to get from New York to California
we have planes now oh you know like we
got so much and ever since hearing that
stand-up I've been just thinking about
like everything and it totally changed
my philosophy on stuff like and and one
and there's another thing he'd say like
I remember an opening stening of a show
he's like turn off your phones don't be
on Twitter just live your life yeah and
when I heard that I was like yeah I
start realizing I don't want to document
everything I do I don't want to record
everything I do or everything I see I
just want to take it in and documenting
what you do should enhance what you do
but it shouldn't become the experience
and I think that's exactly how about
that for a change in society of people
now that are addicted to social media
and their their currency for connection
is simply likes and comments on a photo
yeah in exactly exactly my question is
what does that turn into mentally down
the road because there's going to be an
imperative there that's going to somehow
shift like I'm not sure what it's going
to be but when you don't know that that
real what the real human experiences
which were connected is you need to be
around we need to be running around
talking but yes is this weird each other
robotic thing because it's like
encouragement but without any of the
with elements so it's like the
mathematical version a management and
it's hollow that way it's like and
that's what you have to go on 100 likes
and something's just feels so comedy can
also be reassuring and not make you feel
alone like like a reference to me he's
not the only comical listen to but Louis
CK when I was broke for many years and
he had this awesome stand up about being
broke go to the bank of [ __ ] yeah yeah I
have to earn ten dollars to have no
money yeah which is like that's
something that like you've set out loud
before yeah in anger and hearing that
was so like yeah there's funny stuff
about being broke because when you're a
broke it [ __ ] sucks but it was so
relieving to find humor in being broke
and it kind of gives you hope in a weird
way like you know it's not so bad
everyone's laughing cuz everyone's
[ __ ] been through it you know let's
assume people don't understand just how
powerful like comedy is like like lie
when they say laughter is the best
medicine like they're not lying about
that there there's like like studies
show that people that laughs so many
minutes a day live so much longer yeah
something we needed to release is
scientifically good for the heart like
it's been proven lapping is great for
your arts a stress reliever man like
think I how hard this world is now how
hard it is to make a living and stuff
and going and just having a moment in
time where you forget everything and
you're just in a moment and laughing
yeah there's some stranger you don't
know making you like for somebody spent
a lot of money go see well that's this
thing is like like making people laugh
like that laughing is the only thing is
like the only emotional response that
creates community yeah is like true you
know a lot of a lot of emotional
responses and things can drive you away
from people or bond you to one person
but laughter is like the one thing where
everyone's kind of agreeing that this
thing is cool and funny you know and and
you're all in the room together like
it's not limiting I never feel like
laughter is limiting yeah um you know
it's like you're it's a shared reaction
we're all on the same wavelength you
know and there's all kinds of comedy
that like that all can be enlightening
like like we did improv and I love
improv like I love watching a good
improv show you know when when it works
man what ya when it gets us in that kind
of improv shows I hate is
someone is just not going along with the
scene and trying to crack one liners
well yeah bet you're doing bad improv
better prevented problem but watching
great improv like watching people become
creative and something so funny you're
like that could be a scene in a movie
right there it was so funny you should
just record this and put this on youtube
like when there's some of that approach
like in second city and stuff like that
because a friend of mine is taking a
class where the kind of thesis is
they're improving out scenes and then
finding sketches within them and then
turning those scenes into schedules do
you get that kind of that step letter
effect is there yeah totally and so I
always feel like each each faction of
comedy like everyone's kind of a mixing
board cuz like stand-up improv and
sketch are all very different totally
like the approaches are different you
feel different doing them so I feel like
everybody is like really like has one
they're the best at one that's in the
middle on one that's kind of the weakest
yeah and then you know well having
occasionally some guy I'll have all
three but what's up special guest man
well just best say yeah yeah I think
that's like the perfect storm they have
you can get all three but I find that
the personality traits on all three of
those type of performers are very
different to the angry bitter was your
stand-ups yeah they've got something in
their chest we got a [ __ ] get the
opinionated ones at once and then the
sketch are usually like a lot of like
very like diehard actors and actresses
you have may give a drama background and
then the improv ER is trap are just are
just a you know usually get like the
drama kids and stuff for one just like
to have fun yeah you know it's like a
they're like a cool a bunch yeah they
get along a lot better yeah well yeah
absent and the sketch but like I find
that there's like the culture and all
three of those forms of our comedy come
from their very three different specific
cultures it's in three different
processes yeah 3 carry completely
different process it's set it saddens me
that people will always narrow down
comedy to it's funny or not funny when
there's so much more to comedy than just
that it's like watching the drama you
don't walk out of a drama ago it was
dramatic burn no wasn't dramatic
imported to try to look at it
objectively like I when I was in my 20s
I didn't care for Bill Hicks at all and
now that I'm in my late 30s like Bill
Hicks is
who I look up to and who I'm just like
how can i how can I craft myself like
through who I am into more of how free
he was with himself yeah and now I find
like I can sit and go down a rabbit hole
before I couldn't watch five minutes out
yeah so there there's a good point for
comedy too and I don't listen more hit I
know what you mean like we I was just
telling you guys about this um well like
okay like today um I was watched today
um Veronica and I woke up to you this
horrible text from her mom her mom was
just totally ripping me apart it's like
she saw the chin she saw this channel
and you know sex comedy is part of the
genre of this of this channel it's a
brand of humor you know it's like like
if you look at actors you got like Seth
Rogen Jonah Hill Judd Apatow and then
you got comics who pushed the envelope
like Louis CK and I even listen to
loveline and they're psycho Mike on
Loveline he's a comedian but he wrote
hostess radio show and a lot of these
guys are married or have kids or gain
cook will even go really far with his
sex talks a lot of the time Howard Stern
Howard Stern right it's just one of the
gifts everybody's like a great father a
great man but this is what is this is
Brennus is what yeah exactly and like
the mom her mom was you know like I
understand it because it's her mom you
know like effort you're I'm just
degrading and I have no respect imes I
make jokes about Veronica but I do the
kind of jokes where I'm making fun of
stupid comedy like Mike my 2nd regiment
yeah my sex jokes are so stupid so
obvious and that's why people laugh
because I'm acting like its original you
know but I'm fully aware it's not a
rhythm mild set someone say hey did you
come last night then I go ah come like
something stupid like like I'm a knee
leg you know that that's dumb yeah like
everyone knows it I know it's dumb but
I'm just saying it and Veronica
sometimes I make jokes too
us and you know like as a comedian a lot
of times that you joke about real life
things and sometimes I just joke about
real things how many people might
swallow that better unlike a stage than
on all of the internet yes really can't
think that's true of the deciding factor
um but so Veronica you know like feels
like even if it's not about her like a
like great woman and I you know I make
women look bad and I'm like I don't
think I've actually influenced anyone's
mind into looking at women a certain way
because everyone everyone's comments are
always like you're digging your grave
Ryan like you're having your lives just
for who yeah like everyone's not like
Ryan you're so right about woman yeah
everyone's always liked you better watch
what you say man so I mean that's a
slippery so because anytime you're not
just saying anything directly you run
the risk of people not understanding it
or not just reading what you want them
to read here's my point if she doesn't
like what would you do she should I hope
she isn't by any [ __ ] like Coke
products or anything from [ __ ] macy's
or anything from most stores that if you
want to talk about objectifying women
that nobody does better in this country
then the [ __ ] stores that we shop
yeah run the ship marketing did so
whenever people take a stance like that
I'm like I can always point out the
hypocrisy in it because it's just like
come on this yest this is just comedy
this is what you do for a living like
get over it its okay its okay its not
you're taking it on is not worry for
your daughter you're embarrassed for
yourself and look I don't to speak for
anybody in them a little high but it's
you know it's that thing of okay this is
an embarrassment to me I don't know why
it makes me feel this way but you know
and then and then it shoots down instead
of maybe looking at and not being able
because it like instantly puts up a
guard ya can't break it down and look at
it properly to be like oh they just for
living he treats my my daughter very
very well she'd they're very very happy
and he provides like I what more do you
want that's how that's what i was saying
i think it says I think there's also
probably too just now I'm gonna like you
know you it hits you how your daughter's
grown up yeah yeah exactly way that you
might not be my just bottle your because
Rana can I go back and forth a lot on
this topic like
it's been over a year we've been dating
and this still becomes a reoccurring
issue because the bit i would do often
when there was a girl on was out hit on
them you remember that Jerry like I do
all I did was obnoxiously hit on the
girl like it was so apparent I was
hitting it wasn't like is he flirting it
was like well on together you've had on
since early and just throughout have
been friends before yeah and so they all
know it's just jokes and that's why
there's girls who've been in like over
40 videos like so many girls because
they they don't take what I'm saying
seriously they're not offended and I'm
unusually not alone in a video making
some joke about women usually there's a
girl next to you lay off yeah usually
there's a girl next to me to tell me I'm
disgusting or I'm stupid or this is this
is weird you know like there's always
someone else to balance it out argue to
balance it out and tell me how [ __ ]
strange i am and how we're done being so
except for Danielle she plays along with
my jokes but everyone else kind of yeah
you need that one girl is nasty but like
you were even talk about imishu mer
earlier Ian and like Amy sure is [ __ ]
naughty is that oh I don't know it's
just like we just want a unisex society
where we could just walk around and we
can't tell if we're male or female like
this there's going to be a little bit of
give and take their and I don't say you
should be a misogynist cuz that's not
right you know women have their their
raipur if it was comfortable with Haley
come on Ian like a throw some pictures
of you in a bikini and something because
that's what they're already so yeah you
know I'm saying and that's how they earn
a living some of them right so it's just
like what are we doing here like
everybody in Hollywood it's good-looking
is making a living off their [ __ ]
looks yeah most of them can't act but
they're really [ __ ] good look to
watching the screen the exact you know
so it's just like yeah if it really
break down the confines of it it's all
like the same it's all it's a jungle
everything's pimped out man you want to
know the [ __ ] truth Jerry LMK highest
[ __ ] it's all pimping out and it's ok
that's just how [ __ ] society is right
and I really want is that weird like
back and forth of like stuff is pimped
out but you also grew up on it being
pimped out so like your your concept of
reality is based on that and I really
hard to break away from I really don't
like grow up on a farm like biopharm
some days
Atlanta she says like yes I want to
xscape it the formative experience is
different I really want to establish up
front though like with my girlfriend I
totally get where she's coming from a
why we make her uncomfortable she's my
girlfriend you know like I don't expect
her to just hey and just to my work you
know there's no sexy was a thing like
it's still like case by case you gotta
see who's comfortable and we already
have do I jealousy issues enough as it
is so I could see how like we've got him
better about our jealousy but you know
Jerry like we took most of the time when
we get in a conflict it usually comes
down to one of us was jealous about
something yeah you know this is so uh
you sure you want to put this back in
yeah I don't mind um very person well
yeah I mean that's what I mean this is a
different kind of format so this format
allows for me to be more personal right
you know what I mean like if I'm doing
stand-up it's not going to be the same
as ryan right do telling stupid I'm not
gonna tell obvious stupid sex jokes
during a stand-up it yeah but what if
I'm bouncing off someone who I want to
make feel uncomfortable to get a
reaction out of them then I'll do it
it's a different format and the reaction
show format doesn't usually offer a lot
of time for me to be really personable I
mean there are videos where I've cried a
lot better videos where I've been really
open and honest but most of the time
it's not a format that welcomes that but
I feel like a podcast in this version
does welcome person ability well yeah
because because people understand
they're gonna be around longer yeah
different it's just a different budge so
yeah and it's like I really wish your
mom could understand she's like I don't
like him anymore and stuff and I really
might take a little really wish your mom
would understand like that it's just the
show like it's just a show and I'm i
never am influencing anyone like well
that's not how you actually live that's
not how i actually live but she feels I
like the greater on the internet and
stuff I mean I I from her point of view
like I can see why she would think that
like I think yeah I again with some
recontextualization you might be able to
smooth it over but like you know if you
run across that it's your daughter and a
lot of stuff like I can understand why
you would need jerk you know yeah I
totally get I don't
expect her to go well he does this this
and this for her like after watching one
of my videos and being shot yeah this is
who my daughter is dating oh yeah why
that's an identity thing it's not
numbers you know yeah exactly you know I
get how would be more of an emotional
standpoint than a logical standpoint oh
yeah I mean where any like when when
something like beg Hickson where it's
like fear were just like there's no
rationale in there because it's not
thinking from that part of the brain
that can ya have a open discussion
discussion with the others yeah i really
wish veronica was here so she could give
like a more clear perspective on her
side too because i don't want to speak
for her i'm just giving my side of the
story yeah I'm in and I was aware of man
elicits you don't want to like yeah hope
you stay together hope you have babies
we have like two babies and adopted one
a black one you gotta mix it up reverser
e ya understand yeah and then i want i
want to talk i want to have two
daughters treat one of them with a lot
of love treat the other one with a lot
of hate a bland started on the Star Wars
phone yeah yeah and then and then since
I want like the evil one to kill the one
I love that way she will be more
powerful in the end when she will be my
bodyguard for life see I feel like I
would be untrustworthy in a different
way with children i feel like i would i
would like pick one and start telling
that kid that likes certain words mean
other objects and just like see if i can
get away with that for time I just
performed weird thought experiments on
my children yeah be like I'm gonna call
everything in this house blue red and
then see if you grow up thinking red is
that I want to talk to one of my kids
with a British accent and the other
moment the Jamaican accent yeah and see
a sec though they'd assume your form
rosso speaking in a british accent the
other one at jamaica is what you
establish is normal at such a young age
that could that could that would be
terrible to do somebody would be very
fancy like right now i bet i didn't
influence a single person who's
listening to do any of those things well
i know i was joking about Veronica not
having kids and me doing that I don't
think a single person was just
influenced going I should do that to my
kid I just want to adopt like no one's
gonna 19
your old Korean twins that's as far as I
Joe and children it's disgusting well
its preferred on on what level I mean
well you're saying you want to adopt to
19 year old Korean twin I think it's the
adoption part of the only one thing
you'd want to do with 19 year old twins
you can adopt them up till like 32 in
Korea I think really what I what I do
I'm till I pretty sure reduce it is the
legal age for Koreans is 30 watchers who
a lot of people do did that southern
Koreans they don't make sure to her 68
years old yeah Deatherage outside I mean
that is true maturity he would be yeah
that's probably what most people should
go that's the first time so wait wait
wait forgive me but uh since we're all
here we're talking at least vaguely
about comedy who's everybody's like
favorites who's everybody's like top
like conan o'brien and i'll be CJ the
most influential peasant and that's real
fast below I want that's my answer to
that question I hear everyone's answer
but I also want to say like even talk
show comedies different like Conan maybe
he could do stand-up maybe he could be
in shows and stuff but talk show is also
another form and I think that's where
I've got in my talk show talk shows like
tippers cuz my reaction show is kind of
like a talk show to me and I pick up on
the people I've been influenced by talk
show wise like psycho Mike from love
line Conan O'Brien and a lot of that is
like saying things that just make you
look dumb or crossing below something
that you know is gonna is going to
garner reaction then you can like kind
of bad yeah and I like and I love people
like I use it ya like like talk show is
almost like improving a stand up with a
partner yeah and Ian brought up mmm
earlier and I think Louie CK does the
same thing that I like about Eminem is
it's funny to see how words can
sometimes rally up someone and just make
them like so like get a reaction out of
people that's why sometimes I like
saying something disgusting just to get
a reaction out of people I know Louie CK
sometimes does that just to get a
reaction out of the crowd he'll say
something just so like unbelievably
disgusting just so you can get the crowd
ago
oh well but by getting the car to go Oh
as well like it's you learn something
about your room you know something
that's going to get a response and if
you're quick on your feet you can probe
it that's kind of funny just to provoke
people who are gonna get provoked also
yeah yeah it's crazy that yeah I don't
know I think like hick she's due to we
could get them most angry yeah there's
something funny about that it makes me
laugh it's like and I makes it deeper
and I didn't grow up on any Kaufman but
I saw the movie man on the moon twice
when I was young and one thing I loved
about learning about Andy Kaufman was he
only did things that made him laugh like
that whole thing with I saw it all on
YouTube to the actual footage of the
wrestler and him on the talk show and I
was beating him up nobody like he wanted
people to think it was real cuz it was
funny didn't you know or like when he
did the when he's like on the show taxi
when he's when he's like just have
static start appearing on the screen and
people will start being in their TV and
it's no one's gonna find that funny but
Annie coffin loved the concept of a
bunch of people at home hitting their TV
because you think there's something
wrong with it you know like stuff and
that did influence me like doing things
that make me laugh and that's just my
brand of humor some people are so
focused on what will make the crowd
laughs I kind of go well I have a pretty
big sense of humor and I feel like a lot
of people probably laugh at things I
laugh at two so when you're in a crowd
setting like you're the only one
speaking like I get it like on the
internet i'm the only one speak like a
lot of time the own was speaking to the
camera of why i can't get away with
saying certain things let's almost
that's often the most if you look across
the board that seems to make for a
certain quality of art form it's like if
you do the jokes that make you laugh or
you make the music that you wanted to
hear that you thought was cool or you
you know made the movie you would want
to see like those things yeah come out
more genuine you just said it comedy and
I wish people would really recognize it
as this it is an art it's an art it's
hard not everyone can do it I don't
think I don't think there is a form of
energy
anything in life I had jobs before where
I was like running a company I was
running a John Deere dealership and then
I worked on massive cranes are in the
country like pulling up you know eight
foot round gears and [ __ ] in a box doing
very very tough work and this is the
toughest thing I've ever had to go
through because this this art form is
about constant failure in that little
mini yeah yeah exactly and that's that
stand up best like what's when you voice
documenta John stand-ups they go what
would you tell what would you tell your
comic they're like if you can handle
either type two things going to say I
can stay out there's nothing but misery
here and then the second thing they'll
say is just like this is about constant
failure if you can handle constant
failure to get to those little victories
you know yeah because you score enough
little victories it turn into big early
and it's also it's also a performance
and I think a lot of people don't
recognize it is that because like
anytime I see Louis CK I completely
forget that he's probably told these
jokes a bunch of times it always a new
our a year though doesn't he like those
I know but he has to practice the bits
at clubs and stuff and I always forget
that he's done that you know it's a
performance he has to make it sound like
he's sort of just talking to you you
know I didn't build Berta's a good job
bill burr does a great job at that bill
burr does a great job at that she's
always wrist you listen handles stand up
like it just sounds like a dude talking
about whatever yeah yeah very very like
slow pace and stuff he's very funny yeah
so I I don't know I really hope that
there might be something here that was
said that if someone didn't have a big
respect of comedy or a kind of just
didn't really see it in this light that
they were somewhat persuaded into
feeling that you know what I should give
comedy a little bit more credit hey what
it is comedy is hard hi moisten it sits
here's the here's the statistics so if I
mean I don't know if anybody listens to
think about becoming a stand-up I never
want to persuade you one way or the
other if you want to try you should
always go for if you love but and to get
to the professional level of comedian
it's where you're making a living the
success rate is point zero eight percent
good
so out of every hundred people that try
stand-up less than one make it out yeah
and and that's a truly now I used to
host everything in orlando like the
improv the bonkers there and I would see
talented people come through and see
some untalented people move through
night I did everything I could to keep
the good ones coming along but let them
fell off and got families get better
jobs lavada gone so just because it's
such a long process to get through to
and it is such a struggle but well it's
the one it's it's more challenging to me
than just being an actor you know I feel
like actor you have to have a large
quantity of rejections to finally go I
don't think this is for me and then
people quit suddenly when maybe you
should still keep persisting and keep
trying like comedy you have to be
persistent consistent keep reworking the
bit keep doing everything and then I can
see how you could get discouraged much
faster because you're in front of a
you're not in front of one casting
director in front of a room of people
who are not laughing at your [ __ ] it's
probably going to discourage you like a
million times more than if one person in
the room didn't like what you did well
with comedy you also have to invent the
material that you're working yes it's
like an actor you can engage with
something that's already there and you
can interpret it and that's a whole
different thought process but when you
have to shop not only yourself but this
thing you invented to people like that's
like well here's it always I always put
is just like actors have to act
comedians have to be the actor the
writer the director of the producer yeah
that's what a comic has to be and when
comics say that it always sounds a bit
douchey but at the same time the element
of how long it takes to move into that
you know until I get all those things
kind of combined and working well
together the writing the Performing you
know you have timing delivery everything
is all has to be there and all those the
moments have to grow and it takes
totally totally see I would kill to just
achieve the level of like you know like
you use you circulate the the kind of la
comedy scene maybe appear in a couple
movies and small parts like yeah I don't
need to like own the world but as long
as like oh yeah Jerry's effaclar go I
know that like late huh i'ma check him
out just to be one of those guys or it's
like oh yeah he was with some other
comics
he's pretty good like like that's the
level of yeah like I just want to be
okay like I look at i saw this i saw
this interview with i mean this this
conversation with jerry seinfeld ricky
gervais is chris rock and Louie CK and
and I was like you know they're talking
serious about comedy and you I i was
listening to it and I'm like wow like
these guys is opinions and observations
do speak to the world you know like
comics believe it or not are way more
influential than we realize they are you
now the thing that's why it's such like
a thing is just not that respected
because I don't think people understand
the whatever what it actually brought to
their life or how it's changed their
point of views because what people don't
understand is is that the only way you
can pull down somebody off of their
opinion is you have to you have to UM
yep them live them emotionally and the
only emotion that gets you to drop your
guard is laughter yeah we were little
you move them in a positive way ya know
it's like we're really a lot harder a
Comics comic can can communicate a
message better because like you never
think about your enemy laughing yeah if
I if that's a guy don't like I kind of
assume him humorless and so comedian if
they can make you laugh you already like
them like you're already apt to to
listen to what they're gonna say I
always feel like it I always feel like
if you want to be a comedian you should
stay in there and because like I went to
watch me and perform at flappers and
there were some comics there who you
know like you could tell they were
really trying and some of this material
might have been knew you could tell they
were beginner level amateurs and which
is on that and stand up for sure and
listening listening to them I was
thinking like okay they're not getting
laughs now doesn't mean they're not
funny though there's a reason they're
trying to do it because a lot of people
probably think they're funny and they
just need to find their groove and
develop the skill we have the talent to
be funny now they need the skill to do
stand-up well I think when you're
breaking into there's also for a lot of
people probably like a period where you
have to break through your influences
because like yeah I start doing stand-up
usually you try to imagine you like okay
so you better
said one hundred percent right on it so
it's like once you learn how it comes
out it comes naturally from you I think
that's when magic starts to happen
totally cuz he knows that that's what I
would always do her shift I'm like
trying to get through and my like my
favorite comedy influences our little
scattered shots I had a lot of
influences that would affect either I
would use them as a as either like a
defense for me against the crowd and it
would never be obviously material but it
might be cadence it might be movement
because then I could kind of where their
skin when I was and I would use them in
a moment that I was growing as a
comedian yeah i'm just gonna just kind
of put this on and see how it works to
like when i first start doing this
should i do now which is a lot more
social commentary i would be i'm like
i'm gonna go in there angry like Burt
yeah so I would like kind of screaming
yelling my point now I'm really like
laid-back and kind of like swore me
about it yeah you know it's weird is I
actually heard some of the best advice
from Steven Spielberg in an interview he
said that the day you just embraced
something long lines of like you have to
just embrace yourself and what makes
unique don't try to be anyone and don't
try to be your mentors you know like
well that's that's like again with like
any art form like study style but don't
copy style you know and I think
everybody has to learn that the by
scraping knees though cuz like
everybody's first thing looks like you
know it's trying to looks like it
remains yeah why we say just like the
kitty uniqueness is vulnerability once
you get the key to vulnerability kind of
down then you can grow as much as you
want to grow in whatever art form your
drill and that's why we say it's like
comedy my favorite comics reason why
Richard Pryor's is one of the best
that's ever walked the earth is because
of his vulnerability that's what made
him one of the greatest and most
memorable you know what I'm saying yeah
and then I'll hear people say that like
we'll talk about vulnerability they go
oh bill burr's not vulnerable Mike he
puts out a very sharp and hard opinion a
lot of opinion that doesn't but that
doesn't follow mainstream and he's gotta
flip the switch and make you start
thinking about it differently which he
does brilliantly you don't think that
that takes fun
we go up there and say okay crowd that
thinks all of you think this way I'm
gonna tell you why you're [ __ ] wrong
and that takes one ability yeah and
that's why birds is I think is one of
the greatest that's ever walked the
planet is wrong he's opinionated and
vulnerable at the same time like that's
what I like about bill burr and uh oh I
had a I had such a good point that like
totally left my brain and it was going
to be a powerful point where you guys
were like yes yeah I'm in agreeance with
you we have commonality now you'll pick
it back up in the roof in the riff
lakelands backtracked a tiny bit what
were you just saying mmm we stood my
bouquet and you're talking about Bill
bird of variability open why he was
vulnerable okay I know it was an opinion
odd or nothing about to go either I
don't know if this is a great point but
the show as an art form stand up comedy
has greatly changed since it started to
you know before it was like here's a
joke uh walk into a bar here's the punch
line you know those I was it there was a
summer where we kept winning tickets to
the haha for some reason no yeah and
there was one one night is like the only
time I saw this guy cuz usually the
lineup was the same every week um this
this is one guy was like straight out of
the 40s or something like just cracking
one-liners yeah like and if there was a
drum everyone would have had it like
they were all a certain amount of
syllables long one liner jokes done yeah
he did it for 15 straight men and
there's very few comedians who are able
to pull something like that off today
modern day style modern modern a joke
tellers are your big nobody does it
better than Dave Attell yeah I want to
talk about just a setup punchline tag
guy you know and when he was around
Mitch Hedberg was fantastic at it too
[ __ ] miss one with it and Stephen
right i think is but but if you noticed
like there's always a very specific
personality to the one-liner kind of
comics mitch hedberg was very specific
in his personality he wasn't exactly the
everyday relatable weird you know yeah
he was jazz music that's what he was
yeah what one Mitch Hedberg had this
thing where he would tell these
one-liner jokes but they were clearly
likey they were clear like this guy
thought of that what did everyone think
yeah exactly
like he found a one-liner about that
thing you weren't looking at in the room
and Steven Wright would do like this
super dry very serious face monotone
delivery like there and who's the big
one from back in the day that the
heavyset guy Ronnie James really yeah I
Rodney Dangerfield very specific you
know that guy was my wife's cooking so
bad i got the only dog in the blog that
begs for alka-seltzer my favorite jokes
he goes my wife is so dumb she's so dumb
it takes her an hour and a half to watch
16 he broke a lot of comedians he broke
a lot of comedians man he helped Jim
Carrey out he helped Jeff Foxworthy out
Tim Allen out Dave Roseanne or big break
did everything he could for Sam Kinison
I mean he was a kingmaker back in the
day of Ronnie touched you you were on
your way and you don't have that anymore
I don't know why we started talking much
is because you brought up Rodney but
anyways I wouldn't know that's a great
point it's showing the evolvement of
like what is now what we expect from
comedy we like I look there was a time
where we rinse like slapstick comedy and
movies then like Judd Apatow came around
it was like let's do the conversational
base banter and now everyone wants that
he threw over Adam Sandler Adam saying
yeah Adam Sandler and Mike Myers yeah
and even Jim Carrey Jim Carrey all had
this slapstick going along and then the
Judd Apatow combi kind of came in top of
that yeah that's a good point with
convert with conversation same thing has
happened with stand up like the big
comics everyone references like Louis CK
Ricky Gervaise you like their mark Mary
Marc Maron they're all conversationalist
you know they're not one liner comedies
and so well we and you know the nice
thing is where I think what's what's
happening is it's just like when you
look at Bill Hicks bill hicks it's like
I'm not a stand-up I'm a social like I
do social commentary but I have no
[ __ ] platform yeah and so stand up
swear I have to go now what you're
seeing is your starting that you're
honestly starting to see now that being
part of the platform up stand up yes
yeah it's like we and especially now now
like like even post that post that
turning point with jet Abbott up it's
like now everything kind of has
weird irony on it where it's like people
are there's more philosophy based stand
up but there's also more like what is
the reality of the bit sort of yeah I
don't know exactly how to describe it
like I feel like in a small way like tim
and eric has affected a lot of things
because people are willing to get more
weird with with him and I know that also
more poignant at the same time I'm
noticing that like even Seth Rogen does
it a lot in his comedies now um and I
just from watching so many YouTube
comedy videos people are willing to go
much darker whether a comedy now we're
like in a day and age where Arthur
comedy has never been more accepted what
and and and the persona thing is
different now it seems like a lot of
comedians now will kind of make you also
realize that they're yeah person like
yes yes life whereas you know like
instead of creating a persona and just
having that be run to Larry the Cable
Guy type thing yeah exact those type of
situations where you don't get it you
don'tyou don't know who they are you
don't know what they stand for yeah and
I've always said those guys always have
a shelf life it's a very short shelf
like they can for whatever reason those
type of guys can shoot to the top very
very quick and then but as soon as the
the whatever i'll call gimmick but
whatever the gimmick is when it falls
once it gets tiresome boom you're you're
back down here where guys that have
something the same think that they
constantly are steady rise takes them a
lot longer but you know you never see
those guys that are like great
philosopher like philosophical comedians
ever like spike in and crap yeah that
different that never happens to them
they have a constant great career the
rest of them yeah it's like you always
be able to relate because that's what
you're doing I feel like in that yeah
it's like you're just keeping track of
life and there's always relevant there's
this person have to say about this
there's a big moment this all the way
update larry the cable is a big moment
in comedy history they'll never forget
it was dane cook versus louis ck when
everyone was saying like Dave room in
Dane Cook was saying when they were
saying Dane Cook stole his jokes um and
I I remember like while Dane Cook's way
bigger than Louie CK at that time now if
you watch it now if you look at today it
seems like no one really likes Dane Cook
but everyone loves Louise EJ your window
where everybody did like Dane Cook yeah
it is the surrounding expense well he
lost like after that hatred started that
little vs. showdown thing that's when
everything like I think that's when
everything started toppling over for him
because every bull started noticing like
his Louie CK stand-up did come out
before Dane Cook stand up yeah so it was
like one kind of see each other yeah
yeah and and actually that was a great
thing about Louie you see that episode
with Dane Cook oh yeah and like you know
just very real dialogue is it is so stem
really talking house like is that that I
say you still think it's just like
you're this ship and this is a vacuum
now yeah miss this ship just shooting
off into space and you just just took a
vacuum just sucking everything up you
know like like owls and twigs and no
name jokes yeah and I was like wow what
an amazing what just showed you how
smart yeah Louie is and not to say that
Dame's are smart but he was one of those
guys it's just like look if you can't
understand that that act wasn't gonna
stay up there that long like that's on
you bro you should just be happy with it
larry the cable guy Dan Whitney he's
like a [ __ ] a violin like at the
clubs and set for the leno because he
lives there he's the sweetest most
humble man ever he was making 50 million
year back in the day well [ __ ] that's
the kind of money was making he still is
the same house he had before you with
ever like ever hit you just like this
week got it understands the business
that's what's up and yeah and Dane
doesn't understand it that well it's
like you know yeah he's asleep but he
just see seems he seems really like
upset when I see him out like frustrated
so it's just like kind of sad but he's
trying to rock star okay well we gotta
wrap this up guys nice to go he's gots
to go he's got to work with this awesome
impressionist right now yeah like [ __ ]
awesome can I did anything you gotta go
uh yeah Jonathan kite if you guys know
oh look from to wait a bit odd Jonathan
kite is following me around we're really
going to orbit I'm his right ear no way
fine no I just did I mean I would I was
like a puny part in this but he just
he's doing a movie for somebody I work
with and I was playing like a ghoul in
that movie so we kind of I mean we're
just sort of bumping into each other and
said all day like more [ __ ] I doubt he
remember but like I keep and then I was
just listening to him on a pod
like he's everywhere in my space right
yeah guys on BuzzFeed this video has
over a million views he does nine
impressions I asked for rock he's a
white dude best Barack Obama impression
I've ever heard besties long impression
I've ever his impression so good he
knows how to write comedy already and
he's only been doing comedy for five
years he's amazing that's like when I
say like I even hate saying that I like
I write for him because like I do right
for him but it's more I just helped him
with structure and move things around
tweak things a little bit but I assure
you he doesn't remember me but just tell
them what's up hey I um anyway guys you
can subscribe to the real rejects got a
lot of [ __ ] on this channel just look at
it there's a lot of [ __ ] and reasons to
GRE is playlist on the channel and dank
ass dubs his podcast city house on the
channel Ian gutowski action performing
in America right now everywhere
everywhere in America and he has a
YouTube channel I I gave him this idea
to start up a YouTube channel yes and
then he uploaded like a hundred feet of
a semi this is like I'm not but every
video I can find it it was it everyone
goes like all right i'll release one
week like [ __ ] just put all over it
was like I'm doing for a day now i got
like i got equipment stuff coming i'm
excited exciting times for me so yeah
guys make sure to check out Ian on his
youtube channel QC some of stand-up bits
is sketch comedy podcast and yes it's
comedy podcast it's got even helpful fed
for mental illness it's got a bunch of
stuff my story I got a journey with
ayahuasca up and he's buddies curious
about DMT I got a series on my journey
with that a bunch of [ __ ] on there man
yeah the but basically my mind is
basically what I'm trying to recreate it
is the e in my mind is there it is the
ingot ow ski cherries hopefully find it
interesting yeah guys check it out and
also check out that BuzzFeed video with
Jonathan kite oh yeah blow away all
right guys take care first